hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for
anime up pro and today i will be
analyzing all of the most recent
developments
in the boku no hero epic war arc
the war is now taking place on two
separate battlefronts as we know
and we just got important updates from
both fronts
the heroes and hero students have just
made some serious progress
they are striking back against the
villains
but the next big threat is just around
the corner
do not let your guard down because the
villains are
just getting started so let's talk about
it if you enjoyed the boku no hero
content on the channel and you want us
to keep it go and please leave a like to
let me know it really does help
and if you happen to be new to the
channel or you just haven't subscribed
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of hitting that
notification bell and then selecting the
option that says all
if you don't do that you're gonna miss a
lot of our videos even if you are
subscribed it's just how youtube system
works
finally this video will of course
contain boku no hero manga spoilers
we're talking about the very latest
events in the story so please proceed
with caution
you have been warned in the previous
installment of the story we left off
with mina
using her acidman technique to cover her
entire body in acid
and she then threw herself right into
the blazing fire around machia in an
attempt to reach his mouth
and force him to swallow that sleeping
agent in honor of our girl mina
the cover page for this chapter is mina
looking super badass
and surrounded by her acid let me know
down in the comments
if you think that mina is best girl i'm
still a momo man myself
but mina is definitely growing on me no
one competes with miroko of course
but that goes without saying as the rest
of the students are trying to navigate
their way around the giant forest fire
created by dobby
we can see that our boy kaminari appears
to be injured
however it looks like he will be fine
because when he realizes that class
1b girl ray koyanagi is supporting his
head in her lap
kaminary is all like lap pillow nice
and you know that out there somewhere
minata is jealous
af but while the other students are
trying to find their bearings amidst the
fire
mina is advancing on gigantomachia she
is obviously putting herself in great
danger by doing this and i'm sure that
she is
quite scared but she pushes on bravely
determined to do her part to stop the
villains
i have to say that i have huge respect
for mina for doing this
there is no guarantee that her acid will
actually hold up for long enough
in these thick flames and yet she is
willing to take that risk
in the name of being a hero if i was her
i don't think that i would be rushing
into a raging inferno acid or no acid so
again
kudos to our girl mina but as mina gets
close enough to machia she hears his
voice
and she suddenly realizes that makia is
the same villain that she met
back when she was a middle schooler
makia was the giant man who had asked
two other middle school girls for
directions and after they didn't answer
right away
makia became agitated and he nearly tore
down an
entire building mina stepped in and made
up some directions just to get makia to
leave
she was absolutely terrified in that
situation
but thankfully she was able to overcome
her fear for long enough to save her
classmates from makia's wrath
hiroshima always admired mina for being
brave enough to act
in that situation with makia because as
you will recall
back then kirishima didn't have the kind
of courage and confidence that mina had
but it seems that upon recognizing
machia mina's fear from that earlier
encounter
suddenly returns and so instead of
seeing herself as a fierce
hero in a hero uniform she begins to
think of herself as just a young
girl again a young girl still wearing
her middle school uniform
this moment of surprise and hesitation
leads to mina
botching her throw her finger slips and
she fails to toss the sleeping agent
into makia's mouth the next thing we
know
makia once again succeeds in overcoming
mount lady
and he manages to throw her off of him
he then begins emerging out of the pit
that the students had trapped him in
and he nearly crushes mina to death with
his gigantic hand
thankfully in the very nick of time the
manly mad lad himself
red ride unbreakable also known as
kirishima comes to mina's rescue and
pushes her out of the way before she is
crushed by makia however as a result of
throwing himself into harm's way
kirishima seems to have taken some
damage tetsutetsu then grabs mina picks
her up off the ground
and escorts her to safety mina is
worried about kirishima and what will
happen to him
but tetsutetsu assures mina that
kirishima is tough
he won't burn up in the flames and he is
faster than tatsutetsu
so kirishima is probably their best
option right now for sedating machia
gigan tomakia finally manages to stand
up all the way and he shakes off
all of the other students who had been
attempting to take him down it doesn't
look too good for the students
at this point makia is out of the trap
and now that he is standing it will be
much harder to reach his mouth
it looks like the student's plan has
failed despite their best efforts
but our boy kirishima isn't ready to
give up
just yet he goes back into his red ride
unbreakable form and uses his sharp
fingers to literally climb up
makia's body until he reaches the
monster's face
as kirishima prepares to throw the
sleeping agent into makia's mouth
toga sees him and she is able to throw
one of her knives at the container
the container breaks and all the liquid
spills out
at first it looks like kirishima failed
just like all the other students
but as it turns out kirishima had a
backup container
in one of his pockets i am assuming that
back when he had rescued mina
kirishima grabbed her container so now
even though one of his containers was
just broken by toga
kirishima still has another one and he
successfully chucks the sleeping agent
right into makia's mouth as the liquid
spills into
makia's mouth kirishima is rescued by
setsuna
the other students then begin launching
long range attacks at makia from the
ground
using what look like cannons the more
machia moves now the faster the sleeping
agent will spread
and thankfully this is the exact moment
in which the pro heroes
finally arrive majestic the magic hero
fat gum and a bunch of others are here
and machia is visibly frustrated by the
fact that these
little flies as he calls them just keep
coming at this point we also see that
machia's jaw
is apparently dislodging from his mouth
and this
outer jaw eventually reveals a smaller
jawline beneath
i'm not sure how or why his jaw became
dislodged
but presumably it will now be easier for
machia to use his gigantic and extremely
sharp
teeth against the heroes so it is quite
possible that this
dislodging of the outer jaw is an
intentional move by makia
this means that he now intends to use
his massive teeth
to chew through the heroes as the pro
heroes prepare to engage makia
the chapter suddenly switches focus back
to jakku
we see endeavours standing on his feet
and looking absolutely
fierce as shigaraki lies face down on
the ground
endeavour proclaims that no matter how
much power shigaraki obtains
the heroes will never yield to his
destruction his destruction which seems
to lack
any sort of conviction as bakuga and
deku look on
shigaraki laughs he says that all the
heroes
hurt their own families in their
desperate pursuit of helping others
including complete strangers these words
that shigaraki is speaking were the
words of his father
who always resented the fact that his
own mother nana shimura
abandoned her family in order to be a
hero shigaraki says that if that is what
endeavour considers to be conviction
then shigaraki does indeed have it
shigaraki looks like he is about to
stand up again
and that is how this action-packed
chapter
ends man i can't wait to see how this
battle in jakku is going to shape up
and the fact that chicago brought up
hurting one's own family in the name of
being a hero to endeavor
suggest that we are likely going to get
that dobby reveal
in this arc so assuming that is true i
am really
hyped to see that happen the big
question is what happens now with
gigantomachia
and shigaraki in this chapter we saw the
heroes and hero students strike
back and now things are finally looking
up for them shigaraki is down on the
ground and makia is
presumably going to be sedated after
consuming momo's sleeping agent
but let's not forget that appearances
can be deceiving
and we have already seen many twists and
misdirections in this arc
alone i mean sure machia might end up
getting sedated
but there is no guarantee that that will
actually happen we still have no idea of
what other quirks
this guy possesses and what kind of body
alterations he has undergone
as a result of ujico's experiments it
could turn out that momo's sedative
isn't as effective as the heroes were
hoping which means that machia may
continue to be a serious threat
in the future and his whole jaw thing
was very creepy and to me that indicates
that there is probably more to machia
and his abilities
than we realize he probably still has
some tricks
up his sleeve over in jakku endeavour
looks like he has taken some serious
damage
but for the moment endeavour deku and
bakugo along with the other heroes
seem to have the advantage over
shigaraki but is that
going to last what is izawa doing how
long can he keep cancelling out
shigaraki's quirks before he makes a
mistake and shigaraki takes advantage of
that mistake to get back to full
power i think that the current situation
jakku
is just the calm before the storm and
in the next few chapters i fully expect
that shigaraki will make
a massive comeback endeavor bakugou
aizawa and the others could be in
serious danger
in the next few chapters although let's
face it deku probably isn't in danger
since he is the main character
oh and this is just a side note but i
personally loved the mina and kirishima
moment
in the past kirishima wasn't confident
and brave and he looked up to mina
because she had those qualities and now
in this chapter kirishima was able to
help mina
in her moment of doubt by rescuing her
and then completing the mission she was
trying to complete
i thought that this was really awesome
on kirishima's part and since i totally
ship
kirishima and mina i hope we get to see
more interactions between them
in the future don't get me wrong i don't
pay much attention to ships and i don't
think they're a big deal they don't have
that much of an impact on the story
anyway
but i would be totally cool with
kirishima and mina getting together
let me know what you guys think is
machia really about to be sedated
or does he have more tricks up his
sleeve
is shigaraki about to make a comeback
and if so
what does that mean for the heroes who
are currently in jakku
finally where does the story go from
here
is this battle nearing its conclusion or
are we just getting started definitely
share your thoughts down in the comments
below
if you enjoyed this video and you want
to see more videos like it please
leave a like to let me know it really
does help and if you happen to be new to
this channel
or maybe you just haven't subscribed yet
please consider subscribing
and hitting that notification bell to
turn on all notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at
anime uproar i want to give a big thank
you to all of our
anime uproar patrons who make videos
like this one possible
an extra special thank you to alpha a
disciple
of lord twigo himself and i can't forget
are the one tier patrons the ones who
rise above
all other clans including ingrata alolan
adam the world
steelers acquired respect pate heffer
jonathan king brandon aviles papa smurf
emperor otaku thomas jones
and kin mano finally big thank you to
all of our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only gilgamesh
nothing but a fan jason wilson king
zeldris anatoly kazatsky angel cruz
cricket xp
joe stanton very gucci alicia octor
jessica kayla fond
hinokami and water bonnie parks
wrathween de ora deadly saint and stern
hawkins if you enjoy our videos and you
feel that they provide value to you
consider supporting us
on patreon even a single dollar will
give you access to our patreon exclusive
discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you